when I was a kid there were lots of
superheroes that I wanted to be but I
can tell you right now from where I
stand with all my experience the real
superheroes are teachers they're the
ones who change the world
[Music]
my favorite uncle was a teacher my
sister's teacher my brother's a teacher
and I have always felt the most
important job in the world his teachers
my hope for every single person on the
planet is that you have at least one I
think of Lyle Jones who was the most
influential acting teacher I ever had
prior to Lyle I can only get to a
certain point he used to say to me
things like you're standing outside the
character it he said you're good don't
get me wrong it's fine it's okay but
what you need to do is to let go and
trust someone like me who did quite like
to control things that was
transformative and there was a moment
for me about 18 months into my course so
this is the patience of a teacher for 18
months you had to watch me being okay
maybe and I remember this one monologue
that I had to give and it all of a
sudden for me it felt completely
different I felt inside the character at
halfway through it was a big audience
was in a theater that teacher and his
big booming voice he stood up and in the
dark I just heard this nurse
finally all of us go through insecurity
and doubt trepidation along this journey
of life and those teachers that see the
best in us and are patient enough to
allow us to grow into that they are like
gold ladies and gentlemen it is now my
great pleasure to announce the top 10
finalists for the global teacher prize
for 2019
they are Andrew Moffitt from the United
Kingdom
Daisy mertens from the Netherlands
Debora Garofalo from Brazil he D Kazu
Shoto from Japan
Martin Salvati from Argentina
Melissa salgueiro from the United States
Peter Toby she from Kenya
soir au revoir from Indian
Wladimir up cassava from Georgia
yesterday is Selda the madam from
Australia and I'd like to give special
thanks to His Highness Sheikh Mohammed
bin Rashid Al Maktoum vice president and
prime minister of the United Arab
Emirates and ruler of Dubai under whose
continued patronage the global teacher
prize has become a shining beacon for
teachers around the world I'd also like
to thank sunny Varkey and the Varkey
foundation for giving us such a powerful
celebration of the work of teachers and
their commitment to education throughout
the world since the launch of the global
teacher prize in Dubai UAE jazz five
years ago it has gone on to inspire over
30 national teacher prizes are know
think thousands of stories of heroes
that have transformed young people's
lives to attend finalists and to every
dedicated teacher around the world thank
you
you